it is my great pleasure and honor to
introduce our keynote speaker for
tonight
dr. Moreau Simon's lamb dr. Monson
graduated from the école normale
superior and received her doctorate in
philosophy from the soundhole de toutes
a civilization Byzantine she's currently
the research director emeritus of the
Sante Nacional de la voce scientific and
she is also the director of the
observatory this image contemporary
research group at the Italia vahana in
Paris
dr. Manson's research primarily focuses
on Byzantine culture and image theory as
well as on the analysis of contemporary
art and on the relations between art
power and politics her groundbreaking
book which in many ways serves as the
inspiration behind today's conference is
entitled image icon economy the
Byzantine origins of the contemporary
imaginary and it argues that the power
and ubiquity of the image in today's
visual culture can be traced all the way
back to the Byzantine iconoclastic
controversy of the 8th and 9th centuries
dr. Mazon convincingly draws a
conceptual thread from the philosophical
Enterprise of the Byzantine era to the
critical discourses surrounding our
media controlled an image saturated
contemporary life dr. Manson has
published widely in France and among her
other notable publications are voir song
local max de vega LaMarche
Patel qu a almost spectator casket of WA
and most recently image a sweep which
was published last year the impressive
scope of dr. Manson scholarly interests
and publications have ranged to include
subjects as diverse as Vincent van Gogh
Michelangelo's Sistine ceiling
contemporary Chinese art and the
evolution of the fashion industry to
name but a few
dr. Monson has traveled all the way from
Paris to join us here today and to
deliver her keynote address on the work
of the Russian filmmaker Andrei
Tarkovsky her talk is entitled
voice and incarnation and contemporary
images patristic thought in tarkov
his phones please join me in welcoming
dr. Mantha I do apologize for speaking
my English with my awful French accent
and thank you in advance to speak to me
slowly from a beginning I was convinced
by to Heidi's birth the Byzantine
history was sustained by real strong
philosophical and anthropological and
political soaked
second Byzantine thought were the
unknown or two unknown underground of
our modernity particularly in the main
field of images at the constituting
condition of power politics power and of
any human community I first coming here
first intended to speak of union without
confusion finally I decided to broach
the same issue through cinema and I
choose my chose Tarkovsky's work
speaking I could have entitled my
communication iconic turn is a
cinematographic term speaking about
Tarkovsky's films as a philosopher
raises two difficulties each connected
to the other the first is a general
difficulty common to all discursive
disciplines of speaking about images the
Fagin echoing the first is that to speak
of Tarkovsky's work is to address an
object that in a singular way creates a
crisis in the speech itself that is at
the heart of images because the poetry
of ikana City
hakuna city produces a commotion at the
art of philosophically language itself
the philosophers voice becomes fragile
and uncertain before the seismic events
that are is films films that put
speculative thought into a state of
discomfort when I look for where the
philosophers are to be found in dark of
skis work I do not find them in figures
of eloquence or theory to the contrary
their only weakness and vertigo are
found
I find philosophers in the bodies of
children in the winds voice in storms or
in a dog's apparition it is these things
that address signs to the professionals
of discourse or writing signs that are
at once tender and violent signs that
concerns meanings incarnation in the
world's body in a sort of shamanic form
alright these signs manifest this
presence of meaning in the figures found
in the suspension of words as if the
coming of the word took place in silence
thus like a burst of indecipherable
light poetic speech arises I will try to
situate my speaking as best as I can
that is to say by testifying to a way of
seeing renouncing all academic
theorizing of the way these work is
you'd opening paths proposing connect
beings a stalker Volker and watcher
because this work is par excellence a
meeting between gaze and thought that
requests that the philosopher makes a
radical return to the site where the
enigma of the visible intersects sex
will the visibility of the word the
Christian Fathers said one day its
incarnation structurally I do not
consider Christians in any way to own
this concept of visible incarnation
because by inventing it they provided
the universal conceptualization of all
images with the model of a renunciation
of all possession of any capturing of
the visible incarnation is the
experience of being dispossessed of
things for the sake of vision the
experience of a Transfiguration of the
viewing for to see an image is to see
things in their absence in Tarkovsky's
films symbols citations and references
are so abundant the cinematographic
theological poetic artistic culture so
ample and present that we could content
ourselves with the decoding we could
yield to the temptation of a kind of
erudite and last year magnetic I spoke
of temptation but I think that we could
instead speak of trap since in the end
recommend Harry Street films are objects
of encrypted and coded communication
each of Tarkovsky's film
can be the object of successive and
contradictory identifications without
them ever having their authenticity
other betrayed are illuminated in any
way no framework impoverishes it
including that of Christian doctrine
infused as an interpretive lens works
freedom must remain eligible in a
certain manner certainly the Incarnation
and Trinity are related to this work but
all but on what level can it be
understood while still maintaining the
Enigma there are mysteries and shadow
there that discussed must respect the
screen is not a jeweled box filled with
meaning the visible is entirely well the
gaze meets not discuss significations
but the meaning of the word it cannot it
cannot be a matter of transforming the
image into a rebus to decipher but as in
an pauline ian enigma to be experienced
the indeterminate and interminable
proliferation of visual and sound signs
reflect endlessly back to strata and
layers of meaning that come together to
construct the plane on which the visible
is inscribed on the screen now this
surface totally preserves the viewers
position and freedom on which Tarkovsky
never imposes an unequivocal religious
message our death what inspires us leave
us free to one our way through these
films with our arms
like any great creator it makes sure the
meaning of what he shows is given
neither
intentionally by him nor allegorically
by the image normative Oracle II by the
word there is no bottom line nor secret
message no last word
the image is open exposed its meaning
yet to come to be constructed by us
therefore each of us to really berate
starting from from the present which is
ours from the history that is ours the
power of an image is founded in his
undecidable polysemy we are affected by
it and it first comes from the energy
that liberates us that was the
fundamental perhaps and true iconic
teaching all these phases in all these
landscapes are our faces caught in the
geology of a world that is forever
ours a world of waste and promise
Tarkovsky did not create icons but makes
iconic thought still living in our
modern world however if I am here I owe
it perhaps two long years spent in the
company of Byzantine images and texts
that nourish the Russian Orthodox
thought as well as to the homage I have
repeatedly been able to give to the work
of the coughs key I will not assume the
position of expert who ever died would
could possibly be an expert in the
matter of incarnation
when I saw Andrei Rublev for the first
my emotion was considerable and I set
out to take each step of hula fashion
all the way up to his resurrection up to
this resurrection of the world an image
I clearly saw the paths of the passion
the lesson of shadows that travel
through the space despite the space of
pain silence and death to lead the
artist from the mute night to the
Paschal light of images I saw the word
and image flow together the chime of
triumph and redemption but this world
totally familiar to the theologian of
our believer that I am NOT was here no
longer the world of icons but truly the
world of cinema a cinema born in Soviet
countries cheering is the icon away from
the church and associating the adventure
of looking to the Constitution of a new
assembly the gathering together of
viewers to whom Tarkovsky addresses
signs that question their servitude or
their freedom thus their desires cinema
produced by the hands human hands and
the gaze of the creator of the film
Avance childhood mirror
stole kur Solaris nostalgia sacrifice
I'll then his cinema connected to the
incarnation of the word
on the screen I continued to see the
firm of Tarkovsky entering slowly into
indecipherable enigma of the visible for
20 years this adventure of the gaze of
looking accompanied my philosophical and
political work on the question of the
gaze in
production of the visible and off
cinematographic works my conviction came
together little by little today
engagement in cinematography production
as a singular signification that has
been associated since its birth to the
history of visibilities in the Western
Christian world will signify that if the
intellectual and spiritual history of
Christianity enabled cinema to be
invented it is in that capacity that it
is also realized related to Tarkovsky's
film I mean that his films inscribe a
meaning that concerns the totality of
cinematographic history the Christian
theory of icon gives its plenary
signification to this work in the mirror
that it shows the path of meaning for
all cinematography comprises the course
key answers for what it does just as all
great artists are accountable for an
image of humanity I could also state
this another way by saying that the
filmmakers freedom is spiritual and
political responsibility is inscribed in
Christianity is more enigmatic heritage
we there the Incarnation is not divine
or religious matter but a human
adventure one understood in terms of
image and the management of earthly
visibility's Tarkovsky cinema is neither
religious nor sakra lysing it is
anthropogenic cinema there man is
created
in the image of humanity Tarkovsky's
places the cinematographer gesture in a
site of historical responsibility as
regards the modern definition of
humanity to film a face is a way to give
birth to humanity itself humanity is
nothing other that the image that we
produce of ourself with the
cinematographic gesture is this
fictional gesture of great gravity since
it works with the world of visibility
that may have taken us hostage the
question is is cinema condemned to be
nothing but the idle industry or is it
something else perhaps for example and
not the question that the church wanted
to resolve that of knowing which form of
power we take in making images is posed
by cinema as an open crisis this
question can be formulated as follows
can be the assembly assembly of films
viewers be constituted by the form of
the film itself as a free assembly of
speaking subject desiring to share a
world for a new humanity yet to come I
could sell laconically that to believe
in the Incarnation is to produce cinema
why do we say in French incarnate on
screen if the doctrine of the
Incarnation was a solemn legitimization
of the visible finally freed from the
suspicion of Vito idolatry then all the
Western art history is a consequence of
this doctrine now for cinema being an
art and an industry the question that is
posed is that of knowing whether it can
be both at the same time without
contradiction or if it can only be awed
by breaking away from the industry or
adversely if as in industry it must
renounce art and it become just idle
producer in short the question is to
know if the freedom for gays the chooses
or does not choose its own freedom
through industry and capitalist in
modernity at freedom and the industries
constraints come together to make us
responsible in return for the meaning
that we wish to give to all visibility's
Tarkovsky's film appealed to all our
desires to see to experience pleasure to
think to speak and so on what are we
going to do about it
he made a choice because for him cinema
is an industry that questions the
destiny of the case cast on the words of
works of the industry itself
his films view cinema as an industry
saved by art this cinema as is his
cinema as a major writing of own our own
history he makes cinemas redemption
operate
in his treatment of the image in the
singular inscription of the visible on
the screen the history of the world is
it or isn't it a cheap ship wreck I
could quote the last film or a long
solid good film socialism about our
shipwrecked
it's another conference within limited
graphic gesture only illuminates the
iconic doctrine of the Incarnation of
which Tarkovsky's vocation is a jubilant
necessary and painful consequence I say
painful and jubilant because the
cinematographic adventure is passionate
sacrificial but also Resurrection all
perhaps and full of hope the gaze is
seized by the poetic enchantments but
inconsolable anxiety of its image each
instant of darkness is fashioned by its
own radiance every word every sound is
perceived in the singularity of a
silence in other words no signs appears
in its compactness to be an unequivocal
thing but the alterity of its
contradiction passes tirelessly through
it and very the important lesson perhaps
of the iconic incarnation I mean the
meaning of what we see is in what is
unseen the meaning of what we hear is in
what is unheard the word in Greek icon
expresses well what the world imago lost
in latin it concerns the indecisive
indecisive and unstable sound loss
resemblance to an absence and
object of uncertainty offered up to
opinion and judgment something which
could be named an on object I like to
speak of zone and membrane it's not a
lecture to this commitment of
incarnation to meaning in the heart of
the industry requires a return to the
Christian device of incarnation cinemas
calling is here no more an Endora tree
of the visible and much less an
addiction to spectacle but an
unconditional loyalty to the world as
was defended and sustained in auto-doc
space of spirituality by the father's
first green Greek than Russian this
means that iconic thought has offered
for the first time a modern and secular
possibility secular possibility of
redeeming the way we look at the world
through refusing a gluttonous conception
of the visible now cinema as a modern
industry of mass spectacle is precisely
the art upon which false the
responsibilities of either the freedom
of the enslavement of gazes thoughts and
body making firms thus engages all
filmmakers to be responsible for the
meaning that is to be given to the
adventure of filmmaking world wild wide
in the visible of good-turing is visible
of good to be consumed or the floral
enigma of sharing in the sensory
Tarkovsky inscribes is filmmaking
gesture in the depth of this
specifically political problematic well
the term political denotes here the
construction of
space shared by human beings speaking
together and desiring separately we can
understand Tarkovsky as a filmmaker
against Hollywood philosophers have for
long time considered images to be
suspect or untrustworthy and thus having
no place of function in the city only
language seemed capable to them of
bringing together universally those who
were divided by the patience and
intimate desires sharing in a vision the
Incarnation was the invention of the
university universality of meaning
through patience and intimate desires
the question was thus that of finding
the universal dimension of this
passionate visible what sort of
visibility needed to be agreed upon to
make the community of desires thinkable
the doctrinal response was as follows
the Sun at the image of the father saved
the image and returned dignity to the
visible to be incarnated is to become
image to become image is thus to take on
flesh when the word was made flesh
it became image but not body thus all
images celebrate the presence of a word
in the absence of a body thus all image
celebrate sorry a complex and powerful
response since from that point on all
image makers will give flesh flesh to
the word if not they will give a body to
idols
and makes a visible fall back into a
silence with no redemption no sharing
and community the passion is the story
of the redemption of the visible by the
sacrifice of a body that consented to
die so that the image would be
resuscitated as the flesh of the world
the history of image therefore has a
passionate mortal and rejection all
history the universality of the visible
if therefore founded not in the contents
of vision but in the meaning that is
produced and shared by the community of
gazers cast upon the image what does it
mean to share a vision
it will never be by definition reducing
a multiplicity of living beings to a
single organs activity each as of us as
two eyes and no known sees what another
sees so we will never be able to agree
on what we see in term of sharing now
what does we share if not language thus
in all images or rather in our
visibility agreement is reached only
throws in visibility of an audible or
silent word but in whose name it's
understood that this multitude that sees
together is a multitude of speaking
subject who flows in connecting
incarnated image here meaning and create
politics the coughs kills film are
ridiculous faithful to this iconic way
of understanding the doctrine
and charges cinema with making the word
earth that is producing the community of
meaning through the incarnation of the
visible but let it be clear that this
meaning is not in the image
since I have dismissed a magnetic where
is the meaning to be found where is it
situated a new laconic response nowhere
cinemas makes the screen into a site
lets sightless site a place where
meaning is not sheltered zone of
turbulence perverted by the winds of
desires let us pursue this doctrinal
listening a little further to get closer
to the weaving together of iconic and
sound signs because in these films the
shot is defined not visually but
temporally the shot is constructed in
the special exigency of listening and
its expansion is not in space but in
time like the musician when scribes is
movement in the singular at architecture
that welcomes a line of sound the camera
can remain immobile and the space given
to the gaze can expand progressively
growing bigger and able to end the
operation of the visible seemed to want
to give the word to Eternity not as the
promise of the world that is outside our
world but in the cinematographic stakes
of the worlds being present to itself in
each moment emerge give
- the act of being born in each
appearing of things and body if to show
is to be heard then what sort of natural
do voices of how do they circulate in
the iconic tradition the voice that
announces like the voice that designates
our voices that authenticates visible as
an index stretched out towards the image
in icons this is called a pig Hefei
epigraphy the inscription of the name
being the sign of the voice that
authenticates the contract between the
visible and meanings invisibility this
is why the enunciation and all
announcing positions of messenger and
conveyor is a site of creation both the
voice which designates and the index
that shows address is an eyes the
addresses address that no does not
release in a message but rather the name
of a breathe direction the voice which
announces the wounds fertility from the
image will emerge the announcer's the
Annunciation voice that belongs to
Abraham's three visitors the voice of
John's precursors all these voice will
announce the arrival of an awaited
figures not a real not the arrival of
the figure of a real truth but only the
arrival of a possible truth yet to come
we might usually believe that human
voices are closer to speech
noises here in Tarkovsky's film it's
entirely the contrary otherwise the
world and nature are birthing with words
and meanings that human ears cannot hear
and cannot and can no longer hear but
these humans this humans speak can make
speeches that all more or less make a
mess of the word words words words we
hear in the sacrifice resounding as well
as in stalker a desperate exclamation
taking taken personally taken from
Shakespeare words not the word they are
idols idolatrous signs this is why the
here enters image as the organ
absolutely representative of the Sinemet
cinematographic gesture in profile or
from behind but they cannot longer fall
victim to the possible Abbess of the
face poetry resonates thus as a reminder
of the power of the word in another art
that of writing but Tarkovsky does not
write in films he incarnates the voice
of things and bodies the voice false
explodes swoops down in though on those
who welcome the word this word that
falls in snow and not as the snow that
patters in the rain not as the rain the
voice that breezes through the wind not
as the wind the voice that issues force
from machines mortars sliding into
footsteps under tires into the explosion
of falling
the voice flowing with rivers streaming
with milk rippling with seaweed the
world is an energy spread out through
all nature such is as in a shamanic
power of iconic force in the world of
the most ordinary things and objects
everything's murmurs are urges a sign
that our ears must learn together a sign
whose desire and mourning enunciated at
the same time but human speech
the soundtrack makes the image tremble
and the voice of actors tells of the
tearing apart of language when it turns
into the desire the word attained by
meaning the sounds of the world are not
metaphors but are seized by the
Incarnation itself the way the image was
announced and took on flesh the moment
the visible came together with words we
are talking here about the word whose
attentive listening and whose trace of
visibility is inscribed by the icon the
poetic word of the poet Father oxen
aitikaf ski refers back to the voice of
the father who legitimates the
visibility of a son and the iconic
productivity of his hands in this space
where messages are sent and received art
of image iconic heart is at once a love
later and hospitality from father to the
son I said earlier that the place of
meaning was nowhere and constructed by
the word breathing through all things
the movement and circulation of visual
and sound science institute despite
everything a space even in its geometry
is fragile and unstable this space is
that of the image on the screen a
tenuous space breakable a sort of
seismic soil no one can stand in without
difficulty one this is the enigma of a
shove stammering and limping world one
walks in his in its zigzagging band of
limping bumping into things one Falls
one designs trajectories in all
direction of the space spaces of a
remark remarkable clumsiness purgative
warring be it I really Kartik
it is a space make of imbalances force
shipwreck as well as flight the space
has no limit no weight and can at any
given moment swell up or empty out it is
a space that asks asks us what it means
to then stand up it is not a matter of
Olding unto a place burned onto oneself
which can only take place in a state of
continuous mobility all stopping
sweetens collapse in an infinity in
which each appearance produces
incertitude in this cosmic extinction
extension of expectations and
catastrophes people move
according to the measure of their bodies
of their steps first step is like a word
generator of humanity how to produce
meaning in such an an assignable
topology in a way solitude can answer
the question of meaning no meaning ever
belongs to anyone meaning is not in the
image nor in a place no more than any
one of us occupies a place that can can
truly be ours our position life is only
an in interrupted displacement an
unceasing game of displacement between
places where nothing can reside settle
find comfortable rest sleep of spirit
but where the word produces despite
everything hospitality a temporary
address we are exiled from our first cry
on separated from our birthplace to
access language and arrive at speech are
intrinsically founded on the ordeal of
separation and sacrifice we must live to
find our voice we must walk to ear it
and listen to voice of any other with no
refuge no rest our memory only offers
these treasures to the desire to the one
who keeps walking never to satisfaction
and as judgment never asset
no one ever sits desires place is itself
placeless even not you topic
thus it is also impossible to assimilate
this works imaginary to a Christian
imaginary because salvation is not in
the City of God somewhere else but here
and now in it in each instance of desire
extreme tension images always operates
between urgency and patience on this
each inerrant trajectory of insatiable
desire the face of Exile and the
traveler are indivisible from the face
of hospitality because the film of
Tarkovsky are constructed as a land in
which all of humanity is welcomed even
though he himself only ever knew exile
everywhere I say everywhere because
birthplace like the maternal bottom like
roots are simply memories flower
nostalgia is inherent to the wandering
of all life nothing is more a broom that
this fidelity to exile an invisibility
in this homage to hospitality coming
from far away and still remaining away
is the only way to let freedom and
alterity
occur thus the inevitable melancholy of
a restless work offers no rest to our
thought to meet and welcome somebody
unknown in the art of hospitality an art
of image is out of hospitality all
things exist only in the flesh
of image and in the present vibration of
voices and sounds Hospitality is
therefore not a biblical allegory meant
to present messianism
and even less so the only dogmatism of
treat Trinitarian theology as we know
the famous icon of Rublev entitled
trinity is first essentially an icon of
the hospitality of abraham i think that
in tarkovsky trinity offers refers to
two things wandering and hospitality in
Rublev every in world Bluffs icon
Trinitarian hospitality constructs the
space of welcome 404 all words and
images the trinity begins when
hospitality begins cinema either land of
welcome work open to the freedom of
encounters which can only produce the
image of them third-party some other
which designates a viewer have a third
place of an address that the creator and
the image of he offers need in order to
find the place of return be nowhere
possess nothing give everything receive
the give of possible and impossible this
is what the three visitors of whom lives
icon announce in reality they are six
persons in prisons three are visible in
the icon messengers from the invisible
world 300 stopping and sharing of the
meal but this meal is served by two
hosts who were real
invisible in the icon learning from the
trans visitors that they will be the
progenitor of the belated child
it's Ark that is a human family three
person a triangle outsides declarative
field beneath our eyes are the figures
of their welcome the Trinitarian figures
of the announcement they came at SRI to
speak this is what cinema death taking
on not only the rendering visible of the
visible but also the invisible all the
Trinitarian inclusions that support the
image outside its frame of camera the
mediation of announcing voices
Institute's an infinite triangulation
demanded by all the effect of meaning
adding in an encounter on the road of a
mouse there must be three to be able to
share the table of meaning the power of
a third is also that of the word between
what one sees and what almost here
turn arity tonality is the structure of
all circulation of science of all
production of meaning the messaging
function the operation of announcements
the use of letters all messaging systems
busy in [ __ ] interplanetary like in
Solaris or intersubjective in other
films are the same the abyss that
separates us from each other is as vast
as the emptiness that separates stars
the irreducibility of India
objective distances can only be resolved
through the crafting of messaging
systems of a pistol epistolary exchanges
self such are the operation of iconicity
giving the form of a dispatch an address
to the circulation of science is so
strongly inscribed in the films of
Tarkovsky that each time his faces
turned towards the horizon that
confronts them or towards another the
names of their necks and their gazes are
pivoting on an invisible axis that is
not that is none other that the infinite
diagonal of address the visible is the
construction of a veil upon which and
through which we see meaning from behind
no one ever turns his back to us we walk
together toward the same unknown
destination because we only know the
name of truth never its face two
biblical texts established this retro
version of the gate in a goddess the
vision of Moses to whom God refuses his
face but lets its back be seen in
Genesis the work of Noah's son who
approached the neck father to cover it
to cover up his nudity but while veiled
and walking backwards the screen as I
have said is not a jewel box of meaning
the chest in which a sacred secret is
taught it is the veil upon which and
through which means
is inscribed inscribed the surface that
offers itself had to be read the screen
is the plane in which the veiled
appearance of meaning is inscribed
inscribed in the same time visible and
illegible memory and rememberings do not
rely on citations of what has been but
is not longer no longer any more than
they do on referring to what is known
read understood stored and more or less
conserved to the contrary memory refers
to an intimate disrupting of all past
reference a disruption at the art of the
most violent shock shock imprinted by
the prisons like Benjamin explained all
a recent ality of her linear temporal
allottee is abruptly recaptured
vertically memory is itself marked by
the seal of disposition but in memory of
capital gesture is played out not the
transmission of meaning but is that the
desired meaning meaning of the voice of
desire here perhaps is the fidelity of
Byzantine thought endless voice of a
desire in the core of icon maintaining
the heat and light of a flame in the
darkness of broad daylight
that is the cinematography gesture the
script that underlies all scripts it's
why nostalgia is never
regret a movement of retention or a
vocation of what is absent but more in
incarnation in the remnants present
phases of what is no longer in war in
all that is present at each moment a
reading of traces and the sacrifice of
control take place to burn to set aflame
is to submit to the fire of all
catastrophes the desire to possess to
worships assigns themselves it
idolatrous Lea everything that can be
consumed must be consumed the idols of
certainty are the rings we live behind
in this landscape of ashes water and
will be welcoming breathe and the
spirits living even vivifying
uncertainties from the beginning on
speaking about mystery makes me think of
course about poles prodigious expression
in the first letter to quarantine that
caliph qualifies our prison gaze into
truth where I say that we only see the
truth in the world dimly as in a mirror
blip on gar RT the sixth open and
enigmatic a mirror that does not double
the world but ethnic matically directs
gaze into a dissimilar space of another
natural it is about conceiving of the
cinema at the enigmatic mirror of the
worlds truth cinema is an art of the
real but it is a real that comes back
with the cinema as the starting point
not its ending point the film of
Tarkovsky includes a mirrors operation
in their Trinitarian tannerite I mean or
if one prefers ternary structure while
the mirror could become a completely
binary specular operator whose
identifying effects are linked in the
fable of the CSIs - illusory and deadly
effects the Pauline mirror likes a
cinematographic mirror
Schwartzel fusional reconciliation this
is a mirror that can also be called
Augustinian as if as it is by its light
that Augustine Augustine sees the
manifestation of Trinity I prefer
tonality the mirror is not an instrument
of specular duplication but the absolute
operator of alterity our reflection is
an image not of the same but of the
other it is about seeing in the mirror
plane the overturning of the spaces
between a subjects real body confronting
the mirror and the intangible image of
the desiring subject meeting the other
in the mirror now cinema is entirely
caught up in this [ __ ] this incessant
procession of Poti and flesh image same
and other the image in the mirror is not
coextensive to the world as its
reflection but it is on the contrary the
operator of the overflowing overflowing
of the m immeasurable there is more
in this world that can possibly be
reflected in a mirror but the rim there
is more in a mirror science that can
possibly be shown by the world the
excessiveness of meaning in relation to
the frame
recall that the great father's says
about images they think that the limited
womb of the Virgin had contained the
word that the finite had us been the
container of the infinite that the
contents was infinitely larger than the
body that welcome to it they called the
Virgin a mirror without blemish coha of
a collector so I think of Tarkovsky's
hand lifts up in front of his face
delimiting with his fingers the frame in
which he will bring forth the infinity
of the visible doing the gesture the
invisibility of the word I cannot forget
this gesture during the filming of
sacrifice where I see him constructing
the space with his body where the word
would be inscribed in time framing with
his finger the infinite in effect it is
in terms of access that we must
understand the distance that forever
separates what we see from what we say
what we say from what we see the world
excelled exceeds science and science
exceeds the world this
incommensurability of science and the
world am sorry create an infinite depth
in the works that designates the world
through signs and submit it to the
freedom
these signs this is why the film of
Tarkovsky are not in a certain sense
analyzable or rather irreducible to an
analyst each element of Thatcher is
gesture each skill surges forth like a
proper name never generically or
conceptually I won't say that it rains
in Tarkovsky's film but every rain in
every rain every drop bursts in an
insistent and sang-gyu ler way exploding
like a cry on the edge of the world's
lips in order to say something that had
not yet been said and which one be said
again perhaps forever the question is
posed again in its surface
how do image and sound produce an
irrepressible temper ality if at each
moment it is all of humanity that is in
danger sweeten with extension then
cinema bears today a crushing
responsibility either it should help her
sleeving live together sharing the image
and the word oh it would serve barbarity
and promote the Endora tree of the
visible Tarkovsky's film testify to his
choosing a cinema the desires life for
Humanity this is for me is real linked
with the original thought of incarnation
and icon I never can forget that he has
paid the price by his own life far from
our world
- to stay yes
as in impossible far whether I can't
forget that he has paid the price with
his own life in an impossible exile from
far from our world to stay closer to
maintain infidelity to our truth thank
you